welcome to episode 81 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i'm joined by dr david
weil
dr david weil is an organ transplant
specialist family and provider advocate
healthcare consultant and author he just
published a book called exhale on may 11
2021 that describes a life and
transplant surgery and critiques
to put it lightly many of the logistical
issues with the current system
implemented in u.s health care this is
information
everyone should be aware of so the
arcane system
of organ transplantation can be updated
did you know
there isn't a shortage of organs it's
physically getting them to the person
that needs them that's the issue
ridiculous fortunately this doctor has
solutions
the book is linked below we discuss
logistical problems
specific to organ transplant health care
his growing concerns in the medical
field related to the misallocation of
resources
and another really scary problem the
high rate of burnout in transplant
doctors
dr weil also lays out his ideas for a
more sustainable system that would
provide more organs for transplant and
additionally reduce rates of burnout in
doctors
while improving the level of surgical
care rendered to transplant patients
if you enjoy this content or at least
learn something consider subscribing
this episode is brought to you by
truelocal trulocal.ca
where i get my meat from in canada use
code mp for free stakes
in your box you may have heard me talk
about this company for a while now
because
i was using them even before they
sponsored my podcast
with trulocal you choose what goes in
your box and they send it to you
they have any meat you want plus some
organs the meat is of the highest
quality what true local does is they
connect you with local farmers
so you get to buy farmed meat
sustainable nutritious delicious
not the typical meat you'd find at your
local grocery chain
it's great with everything that's
happened due to covid to support local
farmers and their families while getting
access to high quality sustainably
raised meat
and you guys know me i'm super picky
about the quality of what i eat
quality food's so important to all of us
but it's even more important
to me because i only eat one thing if
that one thing
in my case meat doesn't taste good then
life would be
slightly harder than it is now probably
much harder actually i recommend their
grain-fed beef wild salmon and their
lamb is some of the best lamb i've ever
had
you can even order some vegetables on
there now too if you're a vegetable
eater
go to trulocal.ca and use code
mp for free steaks in your box
trulocal.ca
code mp i hope you enjoy this episode
[Music]
dr david weil welcome to my podcast
thank you great to be here can we start
off
uh by you giving a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
or did sure yeah sure i'm a transplant
doctor so i've been involved in the lung
transplant space for 25 years
and most of my practice was either
focused on lung transplantation itself
or advanced lung disease
now i serve as a consultant to a number
of transplant programs
did you recently write a book i did
i wrote a book called exhale hope
healing and a life and transplant
okay we'll get into that a bit but the
reason i wanted to have you on is
because
you wrote an article for the wall street
journal
called supply isn't the problem with
organ transplants
which so i'd like you to get into a bit
of that
about organ transplant supply and the
problems there
yeah the um the issue in our country is
you know one of logistics and
distribution so
if you break it down getting organs to
transplant centers is a
is a chain supply issue really if you
break
it down that simply so basically
there's 60 to 100 transplant programs
scattered throughout the united states
and
our organ donors come from thousands of
hospitals across the country so
24 7 365 transplant teams at the
transplant hospitals have to essentially
organize and get themselves out
to a transplant donor hospital
and get those organs back to the to the
mothership
and it sounds very simple but but it's
really not
given that the the logistics involved
and so one of you know my things that
i've been working on over the course of
my career
is the notion that we don't actually
have a
organ supply issue which i think is
commonly um
a commonly held belief among transplant
doctors and probably the lay public
we really have a logistics issue of
getting all the organs that are
available out there
to the people that need them at
transplant hospitals
what are the waiting lists like and does
it depend on
what organ you're waiting for yeah so we
do four solid organ transplants as
hearts lungs kidneys and liver and total
in total there's about 120
000 people at any one time waiting for a
transplant across the country
and that of course varies by organ
kidney is
the biggest by volume transplant that's
done in the united states
and so you can see with 120 000 people
waiting any one time
there's people transplant centers
and transplant doctors and surgeons
crisscrossing the country
night after night day after day hour
after hour to get the organs to the
people
that need them in my view that's
probably not the best way to do it
i would like to see a system where it's
not wholly dependent on the transplant
center
going to get the organs but rather those
organs actually coming to the transplant
hospital
i think that would be better for
patients and certainly better for the
transplant teams that actually have to
do this work
yeah well i'm a bit surprised that
that's how it works i would have thought
it worked the way
you just said would be an improvement
yeah it's interesting that you mentioned
the wall street journal article because
after
after i wrote it i not only got a lot of
feedback from the transplant community
that i guess
one would expect but i also got a lot of
phone calls and emails from distribution
experts
so people at amazon and walmart
and fedex calling me up saying
this seems like a piece of cake we we
actually move things all over the world
and i don't see why we can't help out
and it's it's conceptually easy to do
but i think from a political standpoint
much more difficult to do which is
frustrating to those of us in the field
yeah geez i can't imagine is
is this because there isn't somebody
that's delegated with the job to fix
this problem do you think
yeah i you know the just like any
problem i think that we
that we encounter in society we ha
you always have to wonder in whose
interest is it
to fix it and in my view
the the biggest interest group
in this equation is the patients right
they're the ones that are waiting on the
organs they're the ones at risk of dying
on the waiting list and i've certainly
seen about
seen that and wrote about that and
the system that we have now was
developed when transplantation was in
its infancy
decades ago and although there have been
tweaks to it
i don't think that it's evolved in
keeping with
how society's involved you know our
ability
to move things across the country
and efficiently we haven't seen
i don't think that kind of radical
transformation and organ distribution
that i guess i would expect given what
we can do in our society
yeah that's pretty scary um i'm from
canada so i'm not as familiar with the
states and the medical system but
are there ways you can bump yourself up
the list like if you have more money and
you can go to a private
center does that mean you get an organ
faster yeah and i've written about this
as well
there's not so much a way to buy your
way to the top of the list
but through many different mechanisms
we've been able to show that their
disparities in transplantation like
their disparities in all of health care
and so access and privilege
and race all go into the mix and
transplantation just like they do in all
of healthcare
what wealthier patients can often do is
list themselves in multiple transplant
centers so in other words
when i was working in california at
stanford
there would be patients that would list
themselves in the middle of the country
where
the organ availability was was sometimes
better
and that's just something that's not
available to people of lower economic
status they don't have a way to get
themselves in the middle of the night
quickly to the middle of the country
so what we found is that some of the
wealthier patients aren't so much moving
up a list
because they buy that access but they're
able to list in multiple sites that get
them transplanted
more quickly and i think that that's an
example of the disparities that exist
okay that makes sense i had my ankle
replaced when i was 17 and
the waiting list in ontario was three
and a half years long
and i i was just like i was in
incredible pain and the canadian
government ended up paying for surgery
in british columbia so we went to a
different province and
it was faster but
i found out at the time that it was
because there wasn't enough operating
because ankle replacements are rarer
than knee or hip
doctors don't get as much operating room
time
so the waiting list was because they
only do an operation once a week
and it was just catastrophic as a
patient
so yeah especially if you're in that
kind of pain that's just that's
that's rough so what made you
um write the book and what are you
trying to achieve by
giving out this information to the
public yeah so when i left stanford in
2016
you know i was frankly a bit
disillusioned with being on the front
lines of transplant care i had been in
the hospital in a very intense
environment for 25 years
and i was
sort of running out of gas just to put
it you know more simply
i wanted a change in my professional
direction
and i also wanted to see if i could
instead of helping
one program at a time try to work more
globally on some of the issues i care
about including
the way we didn't distribute organs in
the country so
i decided to move back home to new
orleans where i'm from
after having been gone for 27 years and
so moved back home and my family was
very interested in doing that
and i have a consulting practice that i
started in 2016 that
that works on transplant related
problems
icu related problems pulmonary related
problems which is
you know a bit in the zeitgeist right
now because of the covet situation
and i had a lot on my mind to
to put it mildly and i wanted to tell
the story
about how transplantation
affected the patients that we cared for
in those patients stories throughout my
book but also
the emotional ups and downs of trying to
do this kind of work
the responsibility that i felt to get
all of the patients transplanted safely
the empathy depletion that i i think i
ultimately had after watching
some patients not do well with the
transplant and
i i essentially needed a break um so
i think in writing the book i was able
to process a lot of
what had happened to me over the last 25
years
and many of us can't do that while we're
in the thick of things we have to
step away to do that and that's what i
did
can you tell me so like i said with i've
had multiple health problems and i've
been on the patient end
of the medical system and it's made me
incredibly disillusioned with
doctors not so much surgeons but uh
but but um more like primary care
physicians and things like that
can you can you give me um a bit of a
story about what it's like to be on the
other side
and what kind of stress that brings yeah
i can't and actually my second book is
going to be about
the loss of trust in health care and we
see it from all different
angles we see it from patient to doctor
from doctor to patient from doctor to
insurance company and the institutions
that are
supposedly keeping us safe but fr
from the from the physician side of it
there's also something called moral
injury
that i think happens among many of our
health care workers and this has
clearly been exacerbated by the covenant
crisis and moral injury in this
instance means that there's a
misalignment
in the value system say that i hold as a
doctor
and the system in which i work so
while many of our doctors and nurses and
other care providers
are doing some incredible things
especially now
they work in a system that doesn't work
and the system often
especially in america doesn't have the
same
interests as the people providing the
care
or in some instances i'm afraid the
patient who needs the care
and a lot of the focus that i'm working
on right now
is how to correct and
and get a better alignment of the people
that are providing the care
and the system in which they work
there's
all kind of statistics right now about
how many patients are i mean how many
doctors are burning out how many nurses
are
leaving the field they're not leaving
the field because of something
internal to them in my view they're
leaving the field because the system's
failed them
and i think that there needs to be more
focus on that that's not to say that
some
physicians and nurses don't have
mental health issues that arise because
of
providing this kind of care watching
young people die watching
people that they put on the waiting list
not get an organ that happens
but i think the bigger frustration and
the bigger issue
is trying to navigate a system that
doesn't work for the patients in my view
any longer and doesn't work for the
providers either
what is it about the system that doesn't
work is it is it
yeah can you go into that a bit yeah i i
think in america
especially uh profit motive
is such a it's such a huge part of the
system
um that it it it overwhelms
nearly everything in health care it's
the way we take
take care of patients how many patients
we need to see
to maintain a practice uh the electronic
medical record where
anybody that's been to a doctor recently
knows that you know there's a doctor or
a nurse
looking at a screen like this while a
patient's sitting over there
talking and the electronic medical
record while
has a lot of potential to do some great
things in my view hasn't delivered
on its promise of reducing medical
errors and providing more efficient care
it's essentially become a billing
tool and it provides documentation
so that the providers and the hospitals
can bill at a higher rate
and so if you had to summarize
you know what's wrong i think the
injection
and the overwhelming profit motive
that's present in health care
you can trace all the problems in health
care really back to that
i also have a fair amount of concern
about the disparities that exist
uh both primarily on a racial level but
also on a socio-economic level where
we've known about for instance racial
disparities in health care
for decades yet very little has changed
with regard to addressing it we've known
about access problems in health care for
decades and
we've made i would i would think really
baby steps in trying to address that
so these problems exist but i think the
root of
of most of them is money
okay so as a doctor like you get hyper
productive people or
incredibly intelligent people going into
the medical field especially
as someone like a surgeon
are you like are are those type of
doctors generally paid
per patient yeah well in america
doctors are paid in so many different
ways it's even hard to generalize
but at the root of all the way doctors
are compensated is some productivity
level
and the productivity level is based on
the number of
patients that are seeing the number of
operations that are performed
etc they're certainly systems that pay
doctors a flat rate
but there's there's i would say most of
the doctors in america
are paid based on productivity and
you know if they want to be paid more
they do more and
they do things that are necessary and
they probably do some things that are
not necessary
in order to generate revenue i think
that
the doctors themselves are usually
at least in most instances not the
problem i think that you know the
doctors that i've seen both in my
clinical practice my consulting practice
are really trying to do the right thing
and i think they're they're heroic in
many ways trying to do the right thing
in a system that
simply doesn't work and what i'd like to
see
is doctors become more vocal in
calling out the problems and i think
that
most doctors feel powerless in the
system
and that's why some of them leave the
practice all together
but they're not they're the ones that
are providing the care
so i think their boys should be should
be heard
yeah i think that's the right idea i
guess it's not surprising that people
end up overworking themselves
and getting fatigued if you get
paid to be productive i mean that
happens in every industry
and it's hard not to do that if you're a
hard-working person
i think that that's right like yeah i
write about this in my book for instance
just the
notion of going too fast for too long
and
some of the folks that have read it and
reviewed it
before its publication are talking about
the applicability of all the
themes within the book to other fields
whether you're a stock trader a lawyer
a journalist you know whatever i think
that the
work life balance you know part of what
we do
is is prevalent in our society it's just
the way our society is built right now
yeah so uh let's first talk about you
talked about racial disparity
um in in the medical system can you talk
a bit about that
yeah it's an it's a topic that i got
interested in a number of years ago with
regard to transplantation because
the literature is pretty clear and when
i was at stanford our group
contributed to this knowledge base
the literature is pretty clear that it
you know with regard to
people of color there's less access to
transplant
there is less propensity to donate
organs
for transplant there's even
once you're on a waiting list less
likelihood that you'll get transplanted
off the list after the transplant
after the transplant operation there's
less likelihood of survival so
throughout the transplant process it's
pretty clear
that they're racial disparities so what
i did is then look to other instances
in healthcare where racial disparities
have been studied and what i found is
that it's it's present in really every
area of healthcare most prominently in
pain management
uh people of color have their pain
managed differently than than you and i
would for instance
that's not they yeah they have
um maternal care that's different
they have cardiovascular care that's
different they get treated for cancer
differently
it's really it's really pervades the
system and it's
in the category i would say of an
unconscious
bias it's not a it's not individual
practitioners
who are racist i don't think it's it's
more
it's so deeply ingrained within our
system
that we we would have to be very very
intentional
about undoing it and in the second book
that i'm working on
i make some suggestions about how to do
that
but it certainly includes a regaining of
the trust
i think rightfully so people of color
don't trust the healthcare system
anymore
and that makes them less likely to
donate an organ
for transplant it makes them less likely
to get a vaccine for covid
it makes them less likely to follow the
recommendations that their doctor gives
them
it it it is a major problem and we we
need to undo it
and i think that one big step in on
doing it would be
to have more care providers nurses
doctors
all the way throughout the healthcare
system be
people of color i think that as a white
doctor
there's been many times that i walk into
a patient's room
and i can tell right away that they may
not trust what i'm telling them is true
okay you mentioned so you said supply
isn't necessarily the problem with
with organs and that it's distribution
does that mean that there are organs
that don't make it to patients and then
just go to waste
that's abs that's absolutely the case
and it happens it happens nearly every
night
and yeah and that's how i feel and i
actually write in the book that not only
do i feel
down about it i get incredibly
frustrated about it because
what happens is it becomes just a
logistical problem and
you know if you can imagine a transplant
program i think a lot of people
think of transplant programs as highly
mechanized efficient
big teams they're actually not they're
more like the mom-and-pop
grocery store they they have you know
pretty shallow staffing
there's not a lot of surgeons and
doctors on the team because there's not
a lot of people with the expertise to do
it so
if they're asked to fly out continually
in the middle of the night to go pick up
organs
from fly from san francisco to idaho to
get organs and back again
there's only so many of those folks to
go around there's only so many hours in
the day
they have other operations that they
need to get done during the day
and so so sometimes the easiest thing to
do is just not do the operation
just basically say we're going to pass
on those organs we're going to wait for
another
set of organs to come up the patient on
the waiting list will be fine
to wait for another set of organs
unfortunately that's
that's not always the case the patient
won't always be fine
and in fact many of the patients on our
waiting list
as they wait for an organ they get
sicker and sicker so they're
they're not as good of a candidate when
they ultimately get transplanted
and they don't do as well as a result
so to answer your question yes there's
organs that go to waste every single
night of the year
because of logistical issues
and also program behavior issues you
know these are human beings that
just can't work 24 7 365
you know they have a limit to what they
can do
so to address that we would have to
transform the entire system
and make it so that the transplants team
stays put
at their hospital and those organs come
to them
okay so just let let me get this clear
uh so you have a transplant
team at a hospital um and
who are the who are the people who are
flying to grab the organ
the usually a surgeon and it's usually
a more experienced pain thank you
shouted from the rooftop so so you've
got um
some pretty high price talent on on the
plane
um flying out somewhere and that person
might be doing heart surgery the next
day
and so it's two in the morning they're
flying out
they they might be doing a
routine heart surgery there's no such
thing as routine heart surgery but
nonetheless doing a scheduled heart
surgery case
the next day and they're flying out to
get an organ
so they have one of two choices well
they have one of three choices one they
fly out
and they're exhausted to do the heart
surgery the next day
no i don't know about you but i'm not
sure i would want to be that patient
number two they just turn it down
just say i'm i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
do it
um you know be you know because
i you know i've got a surgery the next
day i i'm just not gonna do it
or number three and this is the worst is
that nobody takes that organ
and my program can't use it and neither
does anybody else because time kind of
runs out
you know by the time everybody decides
that they're not going to take the organ
um so it it's not it's not a
not a good situation
no that's catastrophic that's terrible
how how long
do organs what's the time frame that you
have in order to get an organ to a
patient
it's it's a it's a little bit of a
moving target i mean we used to kind of
say that you know
we basically have four to six hours to
get
an organ out of a patient and into
another and so if we fly out from
florida to north carolina to get
an organ to come back the clock runs and
we have about four to six hours to get
it in
there's new technology that exists that
and in full disclosure i sit on the
board of one of the companies that
has developed this tech kind of
technology called transmedics
but it keeps the organ alive for a
longer period of time
and in fact it's might be 24 hours it
might be 48 hours it might be 72 hours
we don't really know what the upper end
is
but one of the most attractive features
of
of these kinds of
organ maintenance devices if you will or
organ care systems
is that they can keep the organs alive
until
the transplant team is ready to go so if
you can imagine
a system that i envisioned in my in my
nirvana would be
the organs are kept alive at some
distribution system
in phoenix or omaha or the middle of the
country
somewhere and there's several of them
scattered around the u.s and canada
and basically what happens is they're
kept alive until they're
they're working optimally and then
they're
flown to the transplant hospital and
meanwhile the
transplant surgeons wake up at seven in
the morning
and go to the operating room and put the
organs in
it makes perfect sense to anybody that
i've tried to explain this to
um but we are a long way
from being willing and able to adopt
that in the transplant community
maybe it's possible that people just
aren't aware this is a problem because
before i
before i you know read your article my
assumption was something like this was
already organized
yeah it's not you know basically what we
have in the us
is the department of health and human
services contracts with
between 55 and 60
oregon procurement organizations ops
and these organizations are non-profit
organizations that
contract with the government to
distribute organs throughout the us
and there are 58 of them so as you can
imagine they're scattered
throughout the country california has
more than one
some states just have one so
you know in doing that it's very much
local
local politics if you will it's very
much of a local endeavor right now
without i i don't think enough national
coordination
and national distribution we're really
at the end of the day
we're really counting on transplant
programs going to get their own organs
and bringing them back
at all hours of the day and night and
you know if we
if you if you imagined a map of the
united states and
trace the air flights all over the
country it would
i think illuminate you know the idea
that people are just crisscrossing the
country when instead
we could develop a system where the
organs come to the transplant hospital
so i'm i'm i'm interested in that
in that idea so these non-profit
organizations um
do they just coordinate between hospital
to hospital or
what do they do they basically and i and
i don't mean to diminish their work
because i know a lot of these folks and
they're trying
you know also to work in the system as
best they can
and and they're being asked to be held
more accountable
for the number of organs that they
actually place versus the ones that
don't get used
but they're they're they're in the
middle really between
the the donor hospital and the
transplant hospital
so they're they're they're they're the
people that
help evaluate the organs at the donor
hospital
and coordinate with the transplant
hospital where the
patient's going to receive a transplant
to get those organs
to that hospital but right now that
especially in thoracic transplantation
hearts and lungs
it's really all dependent on transplant
teams going out to get to get them
versus
the organs coming to them i um
i think until we flip that script
we're likely not going to make a lot of
progress in
using all the organs that are available
to us
yeah well it's absolutely ridiculous to
expect a surgeon
the surgeon or one of the surgeons to go
on a plane
and wear themselves out before a surgery
like
you'd think you could get some sort of
delivery person that would be fairly
cheap that could be or multiple delivery
people that would be available at every
hospital to be able to do that
that doesn't sound expensive given how
expensive
some of these surgeries are no it's not
and you know in a system that i
i envisioned you would actually set up a
national network where you would hire
you know a group of surgeons that want
to just procure organs they don't
necessarily want to do the transplant
operation
and they would they would essentially be
procuring organs from the
central regional centers and procuring
them and keeping them alive with the
technologies that we have
available to us and then ultimately
someone
not a surgeon accompanies the organ back
to the transplant hospital and
it gets implanted and it's not
that notion is not futuristic
uh it's availa it's it's available to us
we've just chosen not to do it
do you have any idea what other
countries do for their organ transplants
yeah it's it's it's different it is
different in each country but
um you know america is unique in that
it it's a large number one so there's a
lot of ground to cover
but even in large land masses like
australia
there's a more rational way of
distributing the organs but even in
australia it's still dependent
on transplant centers going out to get
their
own organs in canada for instance one of
the best
lung transplant programs in the world is
in toronto
and you know they do a great job
of going out to get the organs keeping
them alive with one of these
technologies and then transplanting
the organs the lungs in this case
when it's optimal you know so i think
that they've ultimately done a better
job
but i want to emphasize that they work
in a healthcare system that's just so
different from ours
and it's the healthcare system itself i
think that is that is the issue in
america
okay so that's shocking
let me see i agree
that's really not good do you have
suggestions for
doctors on how to balance work and
home life so that they don't burn out
because i know
i know the suicide rate among health
professionals is high and i
imagine that that's partly because of
all the responsibility you bear when
you're trying to help somebody
so do you have any words of wisdom for
them on and whatnot
yeah yeah i've thought a lot about this
you know i think the key
um to staying healthy doing this kind of
work is connectedness
and you know for me it involved three
things really it involved
staying connected to my family my
friends
and my faith you know so i i call it the
three f's
um and i think that when i was not doing
as well
i got isolated from my friends um at
times my family
and i think you know having faith in my
life
kind of later in life helped me quite a
bit because i realized
or i came to understand at least that
the burden of saving a patient
was not entirely mine and
i looked at it that way but as i
understood
religion a little bit better in my own
faith i began to
to sort of realize that you know like as
as as good as i think i am at my job
whether a patient lives or doesn't live
isn't wholly my responsibility
but i i went most of my career actually
thinking that it was and i write about
that in the book i
i i i
bore all of that responsibility which is
kind of an overwhelming
responsibility to walk around with and i
don't think it was until later in my
career that i realized that that was
faulty thinking
and i think i would encourage the
younger doctors and nurses out there
you know to think about that look
they're actors they're important actors
you know in a very large large play
and they have to understand that there's
other forces involved and for me it's
spiritual ones yeah well it's a
double-edged sword right
because if you don't take enough
responsibility then you don't feel the
pressure to try and if you take too much
responsibility then
one thing goes wrong and you're
completely destroyed even if you've
helped
countless other people that that's right
and i
and and i knew particularly that i was
having issues
you know keeping all of that in balance
when i no longer remembered the patients
that we had saved and i could only
focus on the patients that we didn't
save and
that's obviously not how you want to
think about it and it took me
you know some time to sort that out but
i agree with you it's like everything
else
sometimes our greatest strengths are our
greatest weaknesses and so
for me it was over committing you know
to to a mission
if you will but not realizing that
there's other forces involved
yeah certainly has coveted changed
like how has covid changed the lung
transplant situation i would assume
is it has it gone up yeah it really has
i
there there's been a couple articles
some of which i wrote and some of which
i was interviewed for
that talk about the coveted lung
transplant dynamic and way back
well i guess it's not it seems like a
long time ago when the pandemic hit but
i wrote an
article saying that
i think some of these patients are going
to be transplanted and it seemed a
little nutty at the time
but it's actually turned out to be true
because i think there's two big groups
of patients
with covert related lung disease and i
think that we have good understanding of
the first group which is
the patient goes on the ventilator due
to cover pneumonia
either dies or recovers but some of
these patients are more or less stuck on
the ventilator i think all of us kind of
have come to understand that group of
patients and that's going to be a big
group that we transplant
can't get off the ventilator they're 35
years old they're otherwise healthy
there's only one way to salvage them and
that's through transplant but the second
group is the one
that i don't think we've talked about
nearly enough and i and i remain worried
about
it's people that got covered pneumonia
got pretty sick from it got over it
but then scarred their lungs and i think
there's going to be
a subset of patients and i'm not talking
about every patient
by any means talking about a subset of
patients
that are going to go on to scar their
lungs and that recovery's
that lung function is not going to come
back and
i think that if they continue to lose
lung function over time
they also may need a transplant down the
road
and so to answer your question yes
transplant number of lung transplants i
think is going to increase
due to covid and i think transplant
centers in particularly
are already being overwhelmed with phone
calls
from doctors at outside hospitals saying
i'm out of options for this person can
you help us out
can you get the person transplanted
so i think in the next couple years
we're gonna we're gonna see that because
i
the the way i look at it pretty simply
is you take the number of patients
people that have been infected with the
copa virus and then you take
the number of people that develop
pneumonia you take the number of people
that are on the ventilator
and so it's it's a lot of people and
i think many of them are going to come
to transplant ultimately
so you mentioned in canada we have a
one of the world's best lung transplant
scenarios
and you said there was some sort of
technology we used that
people in the states aren't using yeah
it's similar to the
um transmedics organ care system that i
talked about a little while ago that i
am on
on the board of it's similar in
philosophy but different in execution
the philosophy is to keep the organs
alive if you will
out of the body perfuse them with blood
you can actually treat the organs to to
make them better
you can actually watch them for a period
of time and make sure they work
the toronto docks and chef khashoggi in
in particular who's a surgeon is
a real thought leader in lung
transplantation has been for
decades has developed a system called ex
vivo lung perfusion
which by its name means perfusing
and ventilating lungs outside of the
body so
it that's an example of a system that
philosophically works the same in that
it's keeping organs alive outside of the
body but has different twists to it
than the transmedics product for
instance
and i think regardless of which
technology you're an advocate of and
there's
people that are techno that are
advocates of the
toronto uh device and there's some
there's ones that are
advocates of the transmedics device
regardless of which technology
you're a fan of technology
technologies like this are a major part
of changing our dis organ distribution
network without them
we can't change it in the way that i
want to which is
keeping organs alive at a distribution
center
and then sending them to the transplant
centers we can't do it without the
technology
yeah i'm really intrigued to
so because of the health problems i've
had i've gone around the world trying to
find
the kind of the proper surgeon to fix
like my ailments
which is tricky because uh different
countries
respond differently to situations so i'm
really interested to see how some
somewhere different um
response to organ transplants like yeah
i i think one thing that's been
interesting is see or something
yeah yeah and i think one thing that's
been interesting about
patients on the waiting list and i've
i've met many as a matter of fact my
father
got a liver transplant and so i waited
you know during that period with him as
well i think they just assumed
that there's a big list and you kind of
move your way up the list as people get
transplanted and when you're at the top
of the list
it's your turn so the next organ that
comes up you get it
but that's not at all how it works
you may or may not depending on the
local factors with the transplant
program
the logistics the night of transplant
you may or may not get transplanted when
you're on the top of the list
and that's the part that i think is
difficult for patients to conceptualize
because i don't think they have any
understanding of how the system really
works
nor should they um because they haven't
studied it
you know like like i have so yeah you
would assume if you wait a certain
period of time
like what's the expected wait time oh
you know four to six months or however
long it is um and then if you get to the
top and be told
well yeah we're we're out of luck here
that's not good yeah yeah yeah and it's
interesting because people on the
waiting list
they always ask how much longer i mean i
think every single patient how about you
know how much longer we tell them
we actually tell them a range like you
just said uh you know we
we tell them three to six months or
something and what's interesting is that
transplant programs become a
community in and of themselves and
waiting patients often know that another
patient you know went ahead of them
or gee you did three transplants this
week but i didn't get transplanted so
they have a sense
that something's going on that isn't
first come first served it's something
different than that uh they just don't
know it
i don't think most patients know exactly
what it is though
yeah and it's no wonder that kind of
community exists if it's a life and
death situation
you're paying attention completely to
everything
absolutely and they start to lean on one
another and you know
they actually form a little support
network which i think is good so
so you said your dad so you've
experienced being a patient not a
patient but
a family member of a patient as well on
the other side
yeah yeah is that what is that what
is that part of what disillusioned you
about what was happening
not as much disillusioned me i think it
changed my perspective of the field so
my father
needed had hepatitis c from a blood
transfusion and needed a liver
transplant wow
yeah he got no he got four hip
replacements he was born with a
congenital
anomaly of his hips and so he needed
four hip replacements the first one at
age 40.
and during one of the hip replacements
he got a blood transfusion which isn't
uncommon and
back then they weren't testing the blood
for hepatitis c
so i got hepatitis c yeah developed
cirrhosis
ultimately needed a liver transplant and
this was about five years into my career
so
it was fairly fairly early and it
changed the way
i looked at the field um you know i was
still
marveling at the field which i actually
i still am
but i also it became very personal to me
the people waiting for a transplant the
people
that are in our care it became
incredibly personal for me
um and in some ways maybe too personal
because you know every patient became my
father and every patient became
you know one of my kids and i i write
about in the book
that you know two things change you know
my perception of
being a doctor one was my dad getting a
transplant
and the second one was having children
of my own because
i transplanted a lot of young people and
i have two daughters and i
would often imagine them getting a
transplant
or their mom getting a transplant or
you know it it changed the way i looked
at the field
um quite a bit but i think it was
valuable being on that side to really
understand the patient care part of it
from my father's experience
yeah i know from some research i've done
and from talking to my dad that
people who tend to become ceos or
surgeons have
more of a disagreeable personality type
so it sounds like
perhaps you're a little bit too
compassionate for the field
yeah yeah i at stanford we there a
number of us went to go get to get these
personality profiles
and um i was very high on the empathy
score and very high on the analytical
score which
usually isn't compatible in the same
person
and you know it does it does create a
different mindset when you're
when you're both so i struggled with
that a little bit throughout my uh
career
yeah but now you're talking about
something that people don't really know
about and that's going to help a lot of
people and perhaps somebody who
didn't score as high and empathy
wouldn't bother
so that's good even though it caused you
suffering
obviously yeah yeah no i i think it
ultimately is probably pretty good but i
i think you know i think the i think the
best
you know doctors do try to understand
what's going on in their patients mind i
mean i
i it's very it would be very hard to do
the job without without that
you know so yeah i agree
okay where can people find your book
when is it available
it's coming out may 11th at um all the
usual outlets
uh your favorite one to get the book and
so it'll be out for
um out may 11th and as i understand it
is available for pre-order now and uh
i'm going to be doing a number of uh
talks at transplant centers throughout
the country
talking about you know some of the
lessons i learned doing this kind of
work which i hope resonates with the
people that are
still doing it well thank you very much
for coming on and good for you for
writing the book it's
really important and i certainly didn't
know anything about this and
i've done quite a bit quite a bit of
medical research so
uh thank you for spreading the word
my pleasure thanks for having me on the
[Music]
show
you